okay uh hello everyone uh welcome to my
presentation
so the title of my presentation is
extensions of serious branching
heuristics
by exploration during conflict
depression
uh this is a joint work with my
supervisors martin mueller and gryu
so without talking much uh about the
introduction
i will jump into uh the meat of the
matter
so a boolean series satisfactory set as
you know it's a
it is a fundamental problem in computing
science uh it has profound implication
in computational complexity
logic and uh artificial intelligence
uh given a set formula of boolean
variables the task of search solving is
to
determine an assignment of the variables
that satisfy that formula
uh if such assignments exist otherwise
uh just to report
uh that uh there is no
there is no solution exist for that
problem
uh uh this toy example over here shows
how is that solver works uh given a
formula f
of these three boolean variables if you
give that formula into a set solver the
set solver will simply say that
under these assignments the formula is
satisfiable
this try example over here is very easy
but
in general set is not that easy in fact
we have very established uh
uh theoretical results that shows that
set solving
is np-complete that means set is hard
in general and it is intractable in
general
however modern set solvers such as
conflict rejected clause learning
cdcl or cdcl has many real-world
applications
uh such as uh it has a pic good
applications in a hardware design
verification
software testing uh encryption planning
and theorem
proving the reason that solver has found
applications in this domain uh is that
cdcl is
highly scalable that means it is able to
solve large formulas consisting of
millions of variables and clauses uh
one uh hypothesis is there to uh
explain that this uh surprising
efficiency of cdcsr solver
is that citizen search over exploits uh
the problem structures
uh of the of the problems that coming
that are coming from these domains
uh so the major contribution of this
work
are these four the first contribution is
we have an empirical investigation of
the cdcl search solving process
to obtain insights on its conflict
generation patterns
and our investigation has identified
a pathological phase in cdcl search
we have as a contribution to we have a
cdcl algorithmic extension
based on the opinion sites that employs
random exploration in another way
and we have also performed an extensive
evaluation of our algorithm
and we also have performed analysis of
the results to reveal further insights
on the algorithm
so next two slides will explain some
background
present some background which are uh
required
to understand the talk i hope i think
like everyone in this room has these
backgrounds but
just i'm just giving uh giving a touch
uh on these uh
two slides so a set solver
uses a uh back jumping tree search
to determine satisfiability so given a
problem you just perform a
research uh two major components of
uh set solver citizen software is uh
branching and propagation
where branching is the operation that
selects a free variable
and assigns a boolean value to it and
propagation is just a
propagation of the logical consequences
of those of the decision
that the server just made so
in cdcl solver in usual uh in initial
operation
branching is followed by propagation but
in
in many cases uh while doing the
propagation
uh a situation called conflict may occur
a conflict is a situation where a clause
cannot cannot be satisfied with respect
to the current
variable assignment stack uh once a
conflict occurs
the cdca share solver calls a component
called
conflict analysis which outputs two
important
uh piece of uh information
one is a learned clause and and a back
jumping level
so a loss uh
uh uh usually prunes the
search space for the solver in the
future so this is very important for the
series of cdcs
solvers so once a
clause is learned a back jumping level
is computed from that learned clause
and the solver propagates as a
solver uh performs a propagation from
that long clause
uh without making a further decision and
the search continues from there
during uh execution of a uh of a series
the solver that solver uh performs uh
many uh restarts
uh where it abundance the current
partial assignment
assignment and uh it uh the search just
starts from the scratch
um so for uh cdcl
conflict generation at a fast rate is
very crucial
that's because conflict uh without
conflict we cannot
learn a clause and without learning we
cannot prune
the search space and without putting the
search space we cannot solve the problem
faster
so getting conflicts at a fast rate is
very crucial for city clear solvers
and um cdcl branching heuristics are in
fact
very configuring for example uh we
uh the the state-of-the-art heuristics
uh such as visits or variable state
independent decaying sum
and learning rate based or lrp uh both
are based on loopback principle
and they tend to prioritize selection of
uh variables uh which are seen in the
recent
conflicts the intuition behind these
heuristics are that
um this such selection will generate
more conflicts if they are selected uh
if they're selected right now and they
will
they will create more conflicts uh in
the future
so for our work we have uh
uh developed uh two uh novel notions
uh the first one is config depression uh
where
a sequence of one or more consecutive
decisions doesn't generate any conflict
and the dual of this conflict depression
is conflict burst
where uh the sequence of one or more
consecutive decisions
generates uh generate uh at least one
conflict
uh this figure over here shows um
shows a a sequence of decisions where uh
each number
shows number of conflicts generated in
that particular decision
so in this figure we can see we have uh
three conflict depression phases uh
marked in a red color uh that starts
with decision number two
and the first one starts with decision
number two and ends at decision number
five
and we have two more conflict depression
phases marked in red
and we have three uh complete burst
phases as well
uh where the first one starts at one and
uh the the second one starts at sixth
and so on so uh the first conflict
depression phase has
length of four because at uh
for four consecutive positions it
doesn't generate any conflict
and the second uh conflict burst phases
of length as length three so it starts
from here and ends it
here so these are uh these figure
illustrates and the conflict depression
phases and conflict brush phases
we have defined two other measures three
other measures
just a quick a quick question
clarification what does it mean for a
decision to create
more than one conflict
sorry a quick just explain what does it
mean for
one decision to make more than one
conflict okay and so
um so citizens over learns the clause
and uh
when it lands the clause uh it uh
propagates from that long clause without
making further decision
so in within a decision we can have more
than one conflict
i see okay okay
so the measures are decision rate
uh number of decisions per restart and
we have cd phase rate number of city
phases per restart
and we have a variety phase length
which is the average of the city phase
length over a round of a solver
so the first contribution is a series of
empirical insights
to get those empirical insights we
studied cd and briefly cb phases
uh with v6 and lrb the the to most
state of the art heuristics for series l
and we used cdcl set solver glucose
uh that uses uh visits exclusively and
uh
we used uh maple comes ps pure lrb
which uses lrb exclusively and we have
used uh
750 main track instances from set
competition 2017 and 18.
with a uh for each of the instances we
have a uh
time a timeout per instance of uh of
5000 seconds per instance
and after uh we pulled all the data and
analyzed uh we have
some interesting observations which are
these uh
number one is uh cd phases occur
frequently with v6
and lrb uh so the left figure
corresponds to the uh heuristic v6 and
the
right figure corresponds to the
heuristics lrb
uh i will focus on the uh visits
and uh that's because we have similar
observations in
both of the heuristics so the left
figure for visits and in this figure we
are drawing
three measures uh the blue line over
here
are for a very cd phase length for each
of these instances
and the orange uh uh dots here
flooring are plotting uh cd phase rate
and and the yellow uh dots here
are plotting a decision rate so as you
can see uh
when the instances are drawn uh plotted
uh
in in the increasing order of uh
average city phase length uh we can see
that
uh that the uh
decision rates are really high when
protein in log scale
as well as a cd phaser uh also high
so they are not as high as decision rate
but they are high
they are quite high so this observation
uh is uh also also hold for dial rb as
you can see in the right figure
and so uh can you remind us what cd
phase rate is
uh city phase rate is uh number of city
phases per restart
okay yeah uh so
these observations has led us uh to
conclude that cd phases occur frequently
with
both of the heuristics
uh the second observation is that for
many instances
average cd phase length are high with
both of the heuristics v6 and rb
so again i will uh uh focus on uh
one only one of these two pictures uh
where the left one is
electron corresponds to vcs and uh right
one corresponds to lrb
uh and in these two figures uh
we have uh we have distributed those 750
instances
into 25 bins uh and
we have the distribution is by a very
serious length of those instances
so a an instance is put into a bin
if uh the average city phase length of
that instance
uh falls within the range that is that
is shown in the
top of each bin so for example for the
first bin
the average city phase length of
each of these uh 260 instances falls
between two and three
and uh and every bins has the same
same characteristics so as you can see
here
a good a good majority of the instances
has a very short city based length which
is
between two and three however there are
many instances for which
we have uh very high city phase length
for example the uh the the distribution
is habitated
as the last being as you can see here
has about
70 instances with a very serious length
of 25 uh and more
so uh in general uh we can have
instances
with uh more with with very high city
phase length
so we have similar observations in here
so uh
city phase are a real thing for city uh
as
citizens are solving
as a uh as observation number three we
have uh
uh observations on burst of country
generation
for both of the heuristics on average
you have observed that
only 25 of the 25 percent of the
decisions
produce at least one conflict however as
uh
i used to i was telling earlier uh one
decision can
lead to more than one conflict uh and we
also have found out how many of them uh
that produce more than one conflict uh
all of the uh contact for producing
decisions
about 61 per 61 percent produce
more than one conflict so uh to conclude
uh our observation on this uh on this
data
we have this uh statement uh complete
bust phases are short
but it is conflict in interns
that is many conflicts are within
generated within a
short span of uh consecutive decisions
so we summarize our empirical
observation uh in this uh
one sentence uh the typical search
behavior of cdcl
contains shorter but conflict in intense
conflict burst phases followed by longer
conflict depression phases where the
search is unable to find
any conflicts
so uh we have cd phases uh where
the search doesn't find any uh of uh
find any conflict and it indicates that
our uh
best known uh heuristics uh doesn't find
uh uh are very are ineffective uh
during the city phases so we asked these
questions
uh can we do better immediacy phase uh
uh like uh can i do some variable
re-ranking
and these questions have answering uh
that our effort to answer these
questions has led us to
the formulation and of an exploration
based citizen framework named x
set so the main idea of accept is
um that emit a substantial city phase
which is a big city phase uh with
non-zero probability
we perform exploration episodes to
identify
conflict-friendly variables where an
exploration episode is a fixed number of
random works
with a fixed number of steps per work
and performing the goal of performing
exploration is uh
to find conflict amid a city phase
perhaps this uh
figure over here and the picture over
here explains uh how the
film test how the uh except work
so in the cells over here uh
in the consecutive cells over here you
can see
uh uh some sequence of decisions
where the green cells corresponds to
conflict burst phase
where the search finds at least one
conflict and
the black uh cells over here shows
conflict depression
decisions in a conflict depression phase
where the search doesn't find any
conflict
so um starting from the sec
decision d plus two we have a long uh
conflict of depression phase and
at the plus eight the search uh decides
to trigger an exploration episode
the tree over here shows uh
a an an instance of an exploration
episode
where uh the explosion episode takes uh
three uh uh three step random steps per
work
and it has three works so each random
step over here in
shown in blue dots uh is consists of a
selection of a random
variable selection a selection of a
variable at random and an assignment of
a assignment of a polarity
uh to that variable and uh in that way
we go up to level three or
uh we go up to the the point
where we find the conflict so the goal
is to
identify variable where uh we we can
have uh
more uh we can have a we can we can
we can identify variables with conflict
and
this sort of random work is inspired
from a monte carlo random works mrw
which was uh
uh invented in in the context of
deterministic planning
so in this uh particular exploration
episode
we have uh only the second work that is
conflict reaching
so how do we use that on the knowledge
we got from the exploration
we reward variables in a conflict
enriching work by assigning some bonus
so for example in the second work
only the variable x and y
will get some bonus and other variables
in other words will not get any bonus
because
the other works are not configuration uh
so
in here x and y will uh in the second
work will receive some received some
bonus
and we uh that we compute the bonus
uh based on the quality of the conflict
called the learn clause that the
conflict are generated so for example we
have considered
lbd as a conflict quantity in here and
uh
while we are while we compute uh the
bonus uh we
give largest bonus which are uh closer
to the uh to the to the conflict
uh for example in here y is closer to
the conflict so y will get the maximum
bonus
most of the bone uh like larger bonus
than uh
x which is further away from that
conflict
and the bonus decays exponentially with
the distance from
the conflicts and this is modeled after
uh temporal credit assignment as started
in reinforcement learning
in x-set we call this bonus as
exploration score
uh so the branch how do you do branching
in x-set
we have extended v-system lrb uh where
we add the exploration score of visits
uh
with the current activity uh current vc
score
and we also add lrb score with
exploration score
for lrp and while we do the branching
except just select that variable which
maximizes the combined score
uh uh which combines visits and uh and
the heuristics code and exploration
scores
so we have performed uh perform an
extensive empirical evaluation of the
uh of our set approach uh we have
implemented a set on top of these
five state-of-the-art uh set solvers uh
and we have
uh 11x set solver depending on how we
combine
uh our extended heuristics uh so
four uh we have four x visits uh
uh four extra solver that employers x
visits exclusively
and we have four expert resolver that
employs
expert b exclusively and we have uh
three
uh solvers that employ a combination of
xvis and x
lrb and for
the test set we have two test sets um uh
the first one is the competition
benchmark
uh which is a 750 main track instances
from
uh set competition uh uh 2017 and 2018
with a timeout of 5000 seconds and uh
the second benchmark we have
uh very hard uh 58 setcoin benchmark
instances
with a timeout of 10 hours
so these are the results uh with the 4x
is extension uh the results are actually
uh
good too strong uh for these solvers
uh the column and the second column over
here shows
so uh the number of distances solved by
the baseline and
the second column uh third column shows
uh the number of instances solved by
our extensions and the uh
the fourth column shows uh the part two
score decrement which
reflects the overall performance of the
systems
so uh as you can see here uh the best
performing
solver is mapple com sps it solves 16
more instances
which is significant it is a strong gain
in terms of set competitions
and we have a good gains with
other solvers as well the minimum is a
one which is a fair game
uh however for uh set point benchmarks
we have very strong gains
for example we have nine more instances
of solved for maple comes ps and maple
cm
uh uh given the number of instances as
uh instance
size like 52 the gains are really strong
for the expeller food explorer b
extension we have the similar results i
am not going through
uh the details but i want to highlight
one thing that
um the maple lrb system which employs uh
uh lrb exclusively
uh the baseline solves zero problems for
the setcoin benches
uh within the ten hours of timeout but
our
extra extension extension solved 46 out
of these 52 problems so
it's like it is solving 1990 plus more
than 90 of the problems
uh for the combined uh from the solvers
where
it combines both of our extensions we
have similar results so i'm not going
through
the details of these uh results they're
kind of similar
so we have performed some analysis of
the solving efficiency
with x set our observations uh
fall into two categories uh the first
one is on conflict efficiency
so our observation is that in general
conflict efficiency that means uh
the quality of the learned loss uh has
good correlation with solving efficiency
that means for for the instances where x
set
uh perform really well they tend to
generate
high quality learned loss on average and
we have second observation on the
average city phase length
so x set uh is uh is designed to
find conflict at a faster rate during
the city phase that means
uh it is it is targeted to uh uh
escape from the city phase uh faster so
we try to uh make it
in line uh which i would like to find
out that uh
whether this uh intuition holds in
practice
so our uh observation for city phase
diversity phase length is this
x set usually reduces a very serious
length
uh that means that exploration helps the
solver to
escape from the city phase faster
so it is doing what it is
this expert is supposed to do
so in this slide i will present a
pathological perspective of the city
phase
where uh i will try to uh connect
uh the city phase with uh uh the
phenomenon of plateau uh in local search
set
and deterministic planning so here is in
heuristic
search uh such a pathological phrases
are not that rare
uh let me uh for example there are uh
tattoos in locus are set where uh
consecutive start stage
uh search that the uh
consecutive states that start visits uh
those states uh doesn't uh doesn't
result in
decrease in the heuristic value uh and
in
deterministic planning uh we have plenty
of regions where heuristic value
doesn't improve over uh uh over over a
long time
so we have a pathological behavior
already in here is a hebrew search
so however cdcl emit a city phase uh
so for cdcl different heuristic values
uh
are uh the different variables has
different heuristic values that means
state state that
search is visiting during a city city
phase uh
have different heuristic values however
none of these states are conflict
reaching that means
on the hindsight uh you can have uh uh
you can
you can tell that uh the cdcl actions of
the uh search
is resulting the resulting into same
decreasing outcome
and in that sense we can uh uh connect
the lack of progress in cdcl emitter
city phase uh
as if it is uh the two to the lack of
progress in
uh ls in plato region and based on this
argument we characterize a cd as a
pathological phase for
cdcl so i'll wrap up my uh
talk with uh conclusion future work uh
so i will summer uh summarize here from
my talk uh we have defined uh concepts
of conflict depression
and showed that cdcl uh leading citizen
branching heuristics
frequently undergo uh through the
pathological state of uh
phase of city uh uh and
for many instances it can uh the city a
very serious land can be high
and uh and the
the situation can uh can be really bad
uh as long as
the conflict changes generated during
the city phase
and to compare the city phases we
proposed uh x
set that apart from uh random
exploration in set search space
uh and the exp etc
was designed to overcome the cd phases
and we also empirical uh
showed in uh sure empirically that uh
our method is effective
on two set of benchmarks
for future um i am interested in
identifying underlying reasons
that causes the silly phases my
hypothesis is that
uh the onset of the city phases which
see the phases corresponds to the switch
between communities
or the sub problems uh that is hidden in
the uh
instance and we identify uh i am i'm
also interested in identifying
characteristics of
set domains and that influence the
effectiveness of the
uh exploration and i am also interested
in uh finding machine learning models
developing machine learning models that
can
uh if it can more effectively handle
city phases such as
whether the model is useful to predict
at the onset of a long
long city phase or uh can we predict a
better
a better variable selection emitted city
phase that
could end the city face earlier
so finally uh some acknowledgements uh
this work was uh
funded by uh answered post doctoral
scholarship uh
an albertan based graduate student
scholarship and a discovery answer
discovery guns from my supervisors
so thank you and i'll be happy to answer
any any questions
thank you so much for a nice talk thank
you very much
uh moshe has a question please go ahead
motion
so i may be missing missing something
very fundamental
but there is a another heuristic
which is really aimed at maximizing
conflict and it's called look ahead
heuristic it's a family of heuristic
look ahead heuristics
and they're aimed at maximizing
conflicts
and i think if you run a solver a look
ahead solver you will see
i predict that you will see a much
smaller number of
of uh of conflict depressions the
problem with
with look ahead it's an expensive
heuristic
and that's why generally unless force
very specific application being
abandoned
but perhaps we abandon it too soon maybe
what we need to do is is a
have a parameter which is a small with a
small probability
use look ahead heuristic and
as as we as we have more decision as we
get into a conflict depression
every time we get no conflict for a
decision we raise the probability
of using a look ahead it will be the
easiest way to find a mix of uh
of a heuristic determined to be very
fast
and with heuristics such as a look ahead
to
maximize conflicts but are slower
yes yes so um
you are absolutely right look at is
expensive
but if we know the right place to
execute the look at uh
algorithm to find uh uh to to to
to find an effective heuristics here is
value for the
states of the current state uh current
state of the solvers uh
then then it would be it should be
beneficial so cd phase is uh is the
place where i'm doing
uh the sort of look at thing uh which is
inter
which i'm doing in terms of production
yeah but i think solomon moshe's
idea actually is a very nice idea
because what he's saying is
instead of doing random exploration
can we consider um
calling a a look ahead uh heuristic at
that point to determine
yes exactly and i i think it's a very
nice idea
that requires further exploration and
then you can compare that with
xsat and of course the traditional
solvers etc
let's do a deterministic exploration of
this idea
oh yes certainly certainly
uh any other questions please
so um i had another question
uh solomon um did you in your work
you showed you know how you use this
random expression but did you quantify
how much time is spent in the random
exploration
[Music]
process i mean so yeah
we are doing the exploration really
conservatively uh
so i i as far as remember it is
not above like uh five percent of
the solvers run runtime in the worst
case
also did you observe that the cd phases
tend to be more
kind of happen with uh say crypto
instances or crafted instances or
something of the song
uh for the setcoin benchmarks the the
conflicts
are are not that frequent so i would say
the glr value for uh
that particular benchmark is above below
0.1 that means in every 10 decision it
gets a conflict
right that's great so yeah for
crypto entrance that i think in uh like
i have observed this only only for the
setcoin benchmarks
but probably in for occupancy this will
hold all right great any additional
questions
if not thank you again for a very nice
talk uh and we look forward to chatting
offline with you and
moshe about the idea all right so the
next speaker
is miss love while